if you're looking to log some couch time
as you try to beat the heat this august
here
are five titles worth checking out on
this week's bench guide
we get it august is long and august is
hot so why not stay inside and binge
some shows
with our list this week you can
celebrate the tv career seth rogen
prepare for a brand new star trek series
gear up for the latest season from a dc
comics character
and so much more starting with our
audience pick lucifer
which carries a devilishly good audience
score of 85
this show is about a dc character
lucifer morningstar who goes from ruling
the underworld in
actual hell to moving to los angeles
where he opens nightclub and becomes a
civilian consultant for the lapd
lucifer was cancelled by fox in 2018 but
given life again thanks to netflix
partially thanks to the performance of
tom ellis who critics say continues to
shine
as the morning star you can manage the
first four seasons and the upcoming
fifth which is due out august 21st in
just under
60 hours which just might feel like an
eternity in heaven
next is our throwback pick taking us all
the way to space the final frontier and
that is star trek the next generation
with five of seven seasons coming in 100
fresh on the tomato meter this was the
first spin-off from the 60s cult classic
featuring a fresh crew
and new adventures on the starship
enterprise and with the new animated
series star trek lower decks coming soon
to the star trek universe now is the
perfect time to binge the next
generation
a show that critics loved for its
powerful depiction of the fascinating
and frightening aspects of space
exploration about
129 hours is all you'll need to binge
this one and if you've got that kind of
time don't forget about all the other
star trek spin-off series
and the movies engage and coming in with
our certified fresh pick this week it's
going to freaks and geeks
despite being a hit with critics this
show about students at a michigan high
school in 1980
only lasted one season on nbc but it
helped launch the careers of stars like
linda cartellini
james franco jason siegel and seth rogen
whose new hbo max film in american
pickle is coming in fresh
critics say freaks and geeks lampoons
real-life adolescents while
affectionately embracing every growing
pain along the way
with refreshing honesty but even with a
bench time of just 13 hours this one
will take
some commitment as it's only available
for purchase on dvd
so if you do get it pick one up for me
too and a dvd player while you're at it
and our under the radar pick this week
is going to the pbs series endeavor
this period drama depicting 1960's era
oxford is a prequel series to the
long-running
inspector morse and follows endeavor
morse through his early career
critics love the performance given by
leading man sean evans calling this show
a handsomely rendered
expertly performed period piece with
twists and turns to keep viewers
guessing
you can binge the first six seasons in
about 40 hours but don't stop there
because season 7 just premiered on pbs
and finally our editor's pick this week
is going to the netflix
dystopian thriller the rain this one is
about two danish siblings who emerge
from their bunkers six years after a
brutal virus carried by the rain has
wiped out most of the population
critics say this danish drama which has
been compared to another netflix sci-fi
hit dark
starts out slow but develops into a
thrilling addition to the dystopia
television genre
with the third and most recent season
recently premiering on netflix you can
bench all three in about 15 hours but it
may put a little bit of fear
into your next rainy day all right
friends hopefully this will help make
your august bench sessions very nice and
very cool for more on all of these shows
head on over to roundtomatos.com
and be sure to hit that subscribe button
and notification bell so you don't miss
out on any future episodes or
recommendations based on the movies and
shows that you love
right here on the rotten tomatoes binge
guide bye
you